okay four more in the story let's go
live now to DWS attesa Volta she's
standing by at the shooting Club where
the main suspect was a member
Tessa a good day to you what do you make
of the new information we're getting on
this case yes as the report said earlier
there are now reports saying that there
might be a network behind the suspects
but I want to say that we have to be
very careful with these information we
have not had any confirmation by the
federal investigator yet so these are
only media reports so far but an
obviously if they should turn out to be
true that the suspect was actually the
killer and that he did not act as a lone
wolf but in a network then political
repercussions would always be much much
larger than they are already here in the
area I spoke to some people and they
were saying it's slightly sad see it
reminds them of the NSU case this was a
right-wing extremist group that killed
many people in Germany with a foreign
background and their last murder was
actually here in Castle so the city I am
in right now and also local politicians
have come out saying neo-nazis are
well-connected here in HESA and they
hope that the federal investigation will
take all of that into consideration
okay now you're at the gun club where
the main a suspect was a member have
there been any reactions there from some
of the members or the people in the area
yes exactly right behind me you can see
the club and I actually talked to the
head of the club and and he told me that
he was very surprised that the the
suspect who was arrested on Saturday and
especially was such a motive he said he
never really struck him as someone that
yeah came out of the group as someone
particular who drew more attention to
him than anyone else he was a quiet guy
he also insists that he never shot any
guns here at the shooting club but he
was responsible for the bow and arrow
section we also went to his neighborhood
the neighborhood of the suspect and we
were struggling
to find people talking to us people are
scared and especially press has been
very active in the area but they were
saying well he never struck us as
someone particular either he was the
family guy who greeted when he passed by
I saw a football laying in his garden
you could see that he's been doing some
work on his house and there was flowers
that were taken care of
so it really looked very idyllic and
people in the neighborhood was saying
yeah they were really surprised that um
he was arrested on Saturday
Tessa Volta for us they're covering the
story thanks very much